let me say something else which outside
the laws are known physics and
this is not something that people
normally even recognize as a problem
i mean they do but they shove it under
the carpet
which is what's known as the collapse of
the wave function
now you see current quantum mechanics
strictly speaking is an inconsistent
theory
that's rather brutal way of saying what
einstein and schrodinger
and even dirac said that quantum
mechanics is incomplete
and the way to explain this is
okay there's a wonderful equation which
tells you how things stay a state
evolves in quantum mechanics called the
schrodinger equation now the schrodinger
equation tells you if you know what the
state of a system is now
the schroding equation tells you what it
will be tomorrow if you like
the evolution of that state is governed
by this wonderful equation due to irvine
schrodinger
the trouble is that it doesn't that's to
say
the way physicists usually use the
schrodinger equation is to work out
certain probabilities of what an
observation on the system would tell you
so what you have to do is you wheel out
of the cupboard
and a measuring device
in this measuring device
you set it on the
the system which is evolving according
to the schroding equation and it
measures it
and the process of measurement does not
follow the schrodinger equation right it
gives you a probabilistic answer this or
this or this
that's another outside the system
problem it's certainly outside the
schrodinger equation right right right
and schrodinger was terribly worried
about this i mean he produced his cat in
the box and all sorts of things you see
he clearly realized there was a problem
as did einstein there's no question
about that
some others didn't well they took a
different view they said look we don't
understand the theory well enough and
that's more that we're saying where
schrodinger's not saying that he's
saying we understand it well enough to
see that that's not the way the world
operates when you make a measurement on
the system
it does not follow the schrodinger
equation and that's what people
understand about quantum mechanics
but it's it's a sort of
vague set of rules about
it doesn't tell you what constitutes a
measurement right
right yeah that's a big trouble that's
the big trouble yeah yeah they say if
you do a measurement then it just
becomes probability for what this or
that or the other but it doesn't say
what kind of a device makes a
measurement
now there's one school of thought
which has been going on from way back to
the early days of quantum mechanics
wigner in particular promoted this point
of view
that it's the conscious being
observing the system and that means
that's what wheeler believed i believe i
really like to believe quite a lot of
people believe that i think von neumann
had a similar sort of view i'm not quite
so sure about his view but
certainly wigner and i talked to vigner
about this
yeah
i got the feeling from thinking he
wasn't quite as dogmatic he was made out
to be on this issue he just thought this
was a possibility i think
but anyway that's people often refer to
it as the wigner view
that is a conscious being who makes a
measurement that's not my view
my view is that it's almost the opposite
of that view that there is
an objective physical process which
which deviates from the schrodinger
equation
in which
the state does collapse so that it
becomes one or the other or the other
with certain probabilities
and that this has to do with when
gravity is brought into the picture and
there's reasons for believing this i
don't want to go into that but there is
reason
i'd like you to go into it if you would
be willing to because i'm i mean i'm
very well it's a very clear mathematical
calculation
there's not a question about it it's
quite what you do with it you see and
what you do with it according to me
is to say okay it tells you that this
system has a lifetime and and it will in
that lifetime become one or the other
without a measurement
it's sort of
that's right yes without what's so
interesting to me that that you're
interested in consciousness and you see
the that consciousness in this
goodell theorem sort of manner
and i would think the most predictable
thing for you to believe as a
consequence of that would be that it is
conscious measurement that collapses the
the the
the quantum indeterminacy the waveform
and yet you don't you think that that it
will that statistical
vagueness will collapse into something
that's essentially is it either or is it
binary
is it zero one
the collapse no you mean probably no
there's a probability it'll do one right
right but when the probability collapses
mean well if it's a two-state system you
see you might have an object which is in
a superposition of here and here yeah
that was direct's first lecture i
remember
and he took out his piece of chalk and
said what
and he was talking about atoms
according to quantum mechanics
or particles a quantum paragraph can be
here
or it can be here
or it can be an estate which is partly
here and partly here at the same time
and then he took out a piece of chalk
and people tell me he used to break it
in two i can't quite remember because my
mind was drifting away from what he was
saying and i was looking out of the
window and thinking about something
completely different
and unfortunately it only came back
after he'd gone on to the next topic so
i missed the explanation
which was probably a good thing
as i think back on it because
probably the explanation was something
sort of to calm you down and stop
worrying about the problem
i suspect it was something like that so
you don't think that conscious a
conscious observer per se is necessary
to collapse the wave absolutely that is
what i
don't i mean i'm agreeing with you i
don't believe that yes but you do think
that if i'm not
mistaken that
the presence of a of an observer in the
universe
that is to say that or the observation
of the universe by us
is that true to say is fundamental to
the universe
not really
that's that's an interesting question
but it's not part of my view
the world would be there
quite independently of whether they were
creatures yes of consciousness yes yes